hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now we
found the island and I mean wow this is
like totally cool but at the same time
I've got a lot of stuff that I need to
do I need to figure out a way to make a
base here using all the supplies that I
have in my base about a thousand meters
away and I farmed up a lot of crap and
it's all the way in the base in the
lockers that has you guys name on it and
I haven't picked any more names because
I'm still recording in the same session
as before so what I'm gonna do now for
right now and I know that I said I was
gonna build a base on here but I don't
have the materials to do that and I
don't have the time to farm it all up so
we're gonna show that for now we'll pick
it up in the next episode but for now I
really really really really really want
to find out what's in this cave opening
so in order to do that I need to get the
tariff terraformer what was the
terraformer
yeah terraformer I need to make a
terraformer that'll allow me to change
up the environment enough that I'll be
able to get what I need in that cable if
I can get to that cave opening I don't
know if I can because it seems to be
directly below me right here
over a thousand meters below the surface
and I don't know how to get that because
that sounds nyan impossible but I'm
always up for a challenge so we're gonna
get there I will be right back after I
get the terraformer and I'll see you at
the near entrance of this possible cave
opening deep beneath the ocean now okay
so we now have the terraformer and I
don't know why I put my knife away cuz
I'm a big dumb doodoo and if you guys
can let me know is there any way to
repair the thermal blade because I still
have it it's still here it's just as at
a durability of zero so if there's a way
to repair that let me know I would like
to know and we'll see what we can do
about that oh oh that's amazing
I didn't know that whoa I can build my
own island apparently Wow
ah that looks scary and weird but okay
it's effective it's surprisingly
effective so I've got 25 material and
now I'm gonna be able to get down to
that cave opening also there's a
geological formation over there also
there's a heat signature then I found
wait where's where's uh John Smith
there's a heat signature this right here
it's a heat signature I don't know what
that means that might just be an area
where there's volcanic activity and if I
go to there I'm just gonna find it okay
no and then I'm gonna burn alive [ __ ]
doc doc yeah [ __ ] duck time to go
okay so we're gonna find it's right down
there now I could I could literally just
dig through the through the ocean floor
and get to there but I'm not gonna do
that I'm gonna what is this wait I've
never noticed this before was this
always here wait wait a minute wait B
this must be the same cave system is
leading to the other one right no it's
not oh my god Oh huh getting out here no
no no no no no no no no you're not gonna
trick me yeah [ __ ] yeah sassy [ __ ]
ain't gonna trick me but this could
leave down deeper and I do not know what
the maximum depth of these caves are and
these could lead way way way way down
and I just don't know it but I have a
funny feeling that it's not quite that
simple okay so I'm gonna be right back
I'm gonna find I'm gonna find the right
place to go for this but I don't know if
I'm gonna find it right away
Wow holy crap Wow Wow that is that is
shockingly effective that I mean whoa I
mean literally whoa that is Wow
thatthat is Wow that what that that is
so effective it made a choir of angels
sing the capacity for my power whoa I'm
just trying to get a a nice path for my
seamoth to go through I did not realize
that the terraformer was that effective
holy crap that is whoa I I guess I
legitimately am just going to start
burrowing down this is gonna take a
while this is legitimately gonna take a
while and I do not know if this is the
most effective strategy but hey it's the
best I got for now and it's it's working
just taking a while warning yep I'm
Rogen's oxygen room I think I ran out of
material that I can absorb maybe in my
terraformer which would be perfectly
understandable considering how freakin
much I did this so I'm gonna go try to
deposit this and in doing so I think I'm
gonna make a mountain I'm pretty sure
I'm gonna make a brand new mountain out
of all this but well oh man I just made
the scariest tunnel that I could
possibly imagine I am the evil worm that
lives in my nightmares I am the
underwater monstrosity that eats through
the entire planet I am the terror in the
night and I am gonna dump my [ __ ] and
block up that vent God [ __ ] that
oh hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa you want
to dance with me I'll bury in a fricken
whatever a mess for me bro scary I
control powers of what you cannot
comprehend you're doing a fiddle with me
I am the one who fiddles with reality
I'm never gonna be able to remember with
escapism there it is there's the secret
portal to Hell I mean admittedly I
haven't made that much progress coming
down here I could probably be a little
more I don't have to make it this wide
is what I'm saying I don't I can be more
sparing with it and I can go farther
straight down instead of carving such a
rounded path Oh apparently I done goofed
and it doesn't like me anymore
wow it doesn't want me to terraform
beyond that point okay all right I got
you okay I get it I get it I get it I
get it I get it I get it a break in the
game I get it I get it
that's not how this goes what I did was
not kosher I should have understood that
when I made the portal to Hell that is
this tunnel I get it okay so the game
does not like me doing that that was not
a good idea I need to find the entrance
to this cave a little bit better I need
to be not so stupid about it which is a
guy I get it I understand I am an
agreeable guy I I kind of understand the
concept of which with it wit with which
you're speaking so I'm gonna go out and
I'm gonna find another way around that's
the nature of the game what are you are
you on entrance to a cave yeah you're
filled with disgusting horrible
creatures damn it
ah stupid human body needs apparently
the game doesn't like me cheating my way
to the bottom so I gotta find a way to
do a legitimate Lea in the vain attempt
of getting down below the ocean floor
which is not going well for me there
to be a way to get to that cave opening
that I'm not understanding it could be
like a way out of the way path that
takes me to the side that goes slanted
down and I need to find that entrance
but the possibility for me finding that
is very slim maybe this I don't think
this is it
ah there's something over here but I
don't think it's a cave opening it's
just to the disgusting okay that's the
other side of disgusting okay so I'm
gonna go try to find whatever the hell
this geological formation is it seems
pretty deep under water pretty far away
and I think I'm about to traverse into
reproter Tory but this might give me a
clue to something else he wouldn't point
me at it if it wasn't something
significant Hackett gave me something as
significant as a frickin landmass the
only island in the game it was just out
of nowhere it's kind of sitting there
where everyone could find it not exactly
secret at all I guess no one's looking
up that's the thing but actually this is
looking very weird I don't recognize
this yeah huh
where is this I don't remember any of
this this might very well be serious
reproduce choir music is picking up
again because I'm assuming oh my god
it's just where that Emperor thing is
where the heck hisses okay we're just in
Balbus territory I've been to Balbus I
don't know what the geological for me oh
maybe it's talking about the thing that
I already found because I did find that
weird cave system down here before I
think this is it yeah I think that is it
this really bizarre geological way
actually wait did I see this whoa that
is weird
okay I'll admit this is interesting it's
a giant rock that's standing on a tiny
crevice like that pretty cool I mean I'm
not gonna deny it's pretty cool but why
did I come out here is there a way to
destroy this so that was a bust so I'm
going to take the heat signature which I
imagined I imagined I actually looked it
up I just looked it up on my phone and
apparently other people are having
trouble finding this - Wow I am very
close to that what heat signature are
you are you talking about the volcanic
vents under where you are talking I
already found this I already marveled at
it ooh ah look at that life is happening
well crafted environments and [ __ ] I
already been there I've done now already
was excited about it I ain't gonna be
excited again okay so unfortunately this
episode was a bit of a bust I didn't get
everything accomplished that I wanted to
accomplish I thought I was on the right
track digging deep underground it may
have just bugged out it may have just
bugged out and you know it could have
been something else about that I mean
this is not very obvious where it wants
me to go for this possible cave opening
I wish
- I could find it and maybe I'm just
gonna have to spend a bunch of time
off-camera just digging in the dirt as
fast as I can trying to clear away a big
path maybe that's it maybe it just
bugged out in that particular direction
but I'm gonna find it I'm gonna do my
best and we're gonna get there we will
get there and if any of you know please
write in the comments down below letting
me know where to go for these things
that wait what hi this is something
there you can't jump dammit how's a
piece for the Cyclops so anyway thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know how to do that and what you'd
like to see in the next video subnautica
in the comments below thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video